we basically rehearse for five months we
take a weapons training tactical
training we did a lot of sparring which
for an actor getting punched in the face
is not something you're used to a lot of
times you know you're like come at me in
this fashion okay good block and that
wasn't the kind of movie that this was
uh you know the fight scene like David
said start here go there mm let me toss
up see what else going you know get on
the table and then end up here no go to
you know and basically like you know I
took some shots you know the guy took
some shots and you know that's a kind of
what we wanted to do I just kept
throwing activities at him again the
fighting the martial arts training the
ride alongs tactical training it was
very advanced tactical training by this
old LAPD SWAT dog 35 years on LAPD and
the guys actually invented a lot of
tactics that are used in you surround
the world today and it was sort of
during that process of trust and with
live ammunition and they're firing back
you know right by each other's heads you
know I saw some sort of trust form there
but I think the big key to this was
rehearsal unfortunately in our business
often you only get actors like a month
prior if you're really lucky and more
often than not a week out and it was
this five months of total commitment
then enabled them to so effortlessly
portray that relationship on camera and
and what you're seeing is for the most
part it's 90 something percent scripted
material and it's difficult Lee scripted
material because it has the cadence and
lingo of law enforcement it almost felt
like a really like a play because it it
was a thin script well I don't even what
was it like 90 pages or something like
that I'm like usually it's like 120 and
it was a lot of dialogue and you know
you want to make a successful movie and
something that you know people like so
there was that kind of added pressure
but it reminded me almost in a way and I
was really enjoying the process of like
a sidney lumet movie like you know I
love those movies like Serpico and
you see that scene when they go to the
party they've all got their shoulders
back and there's something about these
people you just wouldn't mess with them
and and when we went the first day of
shooting at someone set because we left
them alone during the rehearsal and Jake
had his shoulders back and I said how's
it going hain jaan bhi kabhi says I lie
awake three o'clock in the morning I
wake up and I think I got to go and
fight crime you know um I imagine him
pulling people over and giving them
traffic tickets on the way home you know
I've written some specs rips that have
gone on to become films and you know at
some point we decided I want to control
the material and it's interesting being
a writer director because I see being on
set in having the cameras and having the
crew there and the actors is kind of the
ultimate rewrite and and because of the
you know the years of writing and the
years of understanding script and
continuity and story and tracking story
points through I can make very fast
decisions as a director on set and not
worried that I'm going to blow out some
coverage I shot five days ago and I'll
throw lines at people live in real time
I'll hit the trailer bang out five pages
asides hand with the actors in middle is
always great by the way they love that
their sides all over the movie if you
take it you know if you look you can see
them taped here and there and that's
usually when they have the bewildered
expression um but it it's you know all
part of the story telling and I think
part of the flaw of the current system
is is everything has to be so dialed in
and so locked down before you even get
to set and we sort of kill the
opportunity for creativity to evolve and
flower and get the better idea and
execute almost in real time but I mean I
love writing and I'll always be a writer
and that'll always be part of my
identity and core expression but I love
directing more than oxygen you know when
I read the script I was like oh my god I
can't believe that you know it has some
of my culture you know what I grew up
things that I went laquinta Nena's like
it you know he wasn't messing around
there's one every week you know and
those are a blast and you know with the
music and
you know this is it was special for me
because it's you don't have a lot of
times where something's written like
this and a lot of the times it's like
you know latin guys like the sidekick or
something and here i felt like i was
telling my own story and i was telling
my story with my family and also with my
brother and you know from the get-go I I
just couldn't you know when they told me
that I got the part I was just static
and you know just kind of took a you
know just a look took a moment and then
this movie in particular like my brother
for instance you know when crash came
out he gave me a handshake World Trade
Center which was one of the first
starring roles that I had you know he
shook my hand and this one he just gave
me a hug